i know at the very end like
what
okay
i know
i think everybody was
so you know choked up by what you left
on the stage today it was the last night
of knockouts on season 21 of the voice
and things got like real emotional i'm
excited y'all during monday's
performances two team legend singers
took the stage and impressed the coaches
in a big way
first up samara brown who covered tina
turner's simply the best
[Applause]
i love seeing you
as an artist kind of perform how you
would at a show and i was like i'll be
there i
loved
the soul and the sexiness you put on the
song you were incredible it was a
flawless performance i love working with
you
thank you then there was shadell who
brought the house down with a heartfelt
performance of chantelle's impossible
[Applause]
yeah and that had kelly all up in her
feels give me a minute because that was
woo
that was really well done yes it's such
an important thing in the knockouts to
show us who you are and what you're
feeling and i know at the very end like
what
okay
i know
it's
really hard to tap into like your
emotions
and still be able to carry the song and
i know at the very end you got very
emotional it was just such a perfect
song choice and you know i obviously
connected to your message and and kelly
she wasn't the only one who had a strong
reaction there's no denying that we all
felt it oh that was so emotional i think
everybody was
so you know choked up by what you left
on the stage today it was really
beautiful and really moving as for
shawdell's coach john legend he compared
her performance to the iconic mary j
blige she really talks to the audience
and talks about her struggles that she's
been through and you feel her emotion
coming through everything she does
and
i think that's what we felt today
i think vocally
you gave your best performance that
you've given and the thing that made it
break through
was the emotion and in the end john
chose chadel as the winner of the
knockout i'm excited she won this
knockout by being connected to the song
and i'm very curious to see how she taps
into that in the following rounds i
think that's the beautiful thing about
music is that you never know when
something's gonna hit you or move you
and shidel like
shook me and it's that wholesome
feel-good energy that drew ari to the
show in the first place just check out
what she told et back in september
before the season premiere i was a huge
fan of the voice i have watched many
seasons and i love watching the show it
always has the best energy and it's just
such
like wholesome inspiring television and
i love seeing the different voices and
watching so many people start careers
for themselves it's like a beautiful
amazing thing and i've always been a fan
and i feel so grateful to be
here you